we have learned that Donald Trump jr.
himself as well as Jared Kushner and
Paul Manafort will all be testifying
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
next week on the subject of Donald
Trump's campaign and possible collusion
with Russia this is a major development
more because it tells us that the
investigation is spreading and involving
more and more people not because we're
necessarily going to hear stunning
things from these three individuals next
week and more often than not if the
person testifying is remotely
intelligent and has been properly
prepared they will actually say very
little they'll use a lot of I just don't
recall I don't I decline to answer it's
very common that what they choose not to
answer it is sort of the most newsworthy
thing rather than what they do say or
answer during some of these hearings but
the big news is the investigation
continues to grow and expand now there
is no doubt that Jared Kushner
is going to be asked about the endless
list of foreign contacts that he
initially failed to disclose
unfortunately Kushner is going to be
appearing in closed session Kushner does
have a security clearance as we as we've
talked about on increasingly under
scrutiny and he is not going to be
appearing in a public session he will
only be in a closed session meaning it's
not going to be televised Trump jr. and
met afford if they show up and and we
are hoping that they do are going to
testify in open session now Paul
Manafort
I my guesses will be well-prepared and
will say absolutely as little as
possible Donald Trump jr. doesn't appear
to be particularly bright he doesn't
have experience with this type of thing
and I think if anybody might
inadvertently self-incriminate it would
be Donald Trump jr. the same way that
his dad often does the only real way
that Donald Trump jr.
could realistically avoid calling more
attention to himself
would be uh if he pleads the fifth a lot
and just says he doesn't remember a lot
of things and that would still attract
attention in other ways because it would
it would raise suspicions in and of
itself but it might do less damage for
him than just kind of speaking
extemporaneously and honest honestly so
I'm predicting a lot of forgetfulness
next week it's going to be really people
are really difficult for people to
remember who they talk to who they met
with what was said but if I had to to
bet on who might self-incriminate I
would say it's most likely that it would
be Donald Trump jr. now there are
questions about whether Trump jr. and
particularly whether Paul Manafort will
actually show up Paul mana Ford's
representatives have been asked will he
appear and they haven't commented
definitively so far it is also leaked
that at one point Paul mana Ford was 17
million dollars in debt to Russia so he
is a guy who is sort of acutely at the
center of this thing and I hope that
they all appear this is increasingly
becoming a follow the money thing and
there's a really interesting article
that I bookmarked I haven't read it
fully yet but I skimmed it in Vox which
says to really understand what's going
on with krump Russia it's actually
useful to put aside the Putin part of it
Putin may or may not be a player but if
you go at it from the angle of following
the money and money laundering which is
a bigger and bigger part sorry I just
hit my microphone a bigger and bigger
part of this thing that following the
money and money laundering is ultimately
what might expose the truth about Trump
Russia collusion so it's going to be a
major week next week and fortunately we
are we are here the entire week next
week and we'll have full coverage for
you the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com/scishow you can make a
pledge of as little as $1 per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad